let's talk about Senator John McCain one
of the sort of growing voices of reason
in the Republican Party particularly in
the era of Trump has been Senator John
McCain now I don't agree with all of his
politics John McCain was actually one of
the louder anti Obamacare voices back in
2010 he's a Republican after all but
still he has been an increasing voice of
reason in the Republican Party in the
era of Trump we've now learned that he
is brain cancer this is not John
McCain's first cancer diagnosis he did
previously have a melanoma diagnosis he
originally had been treated for a blood
clot in his eye I believe what was the
the original way that this was reported
and ultimately it was learned that he
has been given a brain cancer diagnosis
and treatment will likely include
chemotherapy and radiation although some
of that treatment will have to be
delayed because he's still recovering
from the eye surgery and he's suffering
from a particularly aggressive form of
brain cancer of cancer called a
glioblastoma tumor and if that sounds
familiar you might recall that Senator
Ted Kennedy was diagnosed with the same
type of brain cancer some years ago a
good friend of Senator John McCain's and
he ultimately lived 15 months after the
diagnosis and the cause of glioblastoma
is unknown there's been speculation
about mobile phone radiation but that's
been so far tested and disproven the
idea some types of cancer are familial
which does not mean hereditary but occur
more often in certain familial lines
that seems to be actually quite rare so
there's not an indication right now that
there's any kind of strong familial
component to this type of brain cancer
and there's been a total outpouring of
support for John McCain from both sides
of the aisle generally a well-liked guy
even from the office of Donald Trump who
previously said you might remember
totally disgustingly
that John McCain is not a war hero
because he was captured and her held as
a prisoner of war one of the most
disgusting and vile comments that we
heard from Donald Trump from during the
campaign former President Barack Obama
tweeting his good wishes for John McCain
and you know the good thing is we can
all rest assured that all else being
equal John McCain is going to get the
best treatment available the best care
available and I wish that I could say
the same for everybody in the country
and sadly I can't and this is you but
because of the conversation that's going
on around the Affordable Care Act and
the repeal and you know millions of
people possibly losing their insurance
it's sad that news like this immediately
reminds us of the political battle that
the country is engaged in but maybe it
might make someone who wants to make it
even harder for people to get the care
that they need to reevaluate what
they're trying to do in the house or in
the Senate or by getting rid of their
state's Medicaid expansion or whatever
the case may be maybe more people in
power will think about the consequences
of their actions because of this
horrible diagnosis of John McCain you
know free market and profit it's fine
right the movie industry for-profit
industry get you know have at it what
else a production of video games or
jewelry make profit off of it that's
fine
but health care I mean people's care is
generating multi-million dollar bonuses
for executives it's generating golden
parachutes for health insurance
executives it leads to campaign
donations for the elected officials seen
as more likely to be friendly to the
health insurance industry and that's a
lot of why we're locked into this
totally corrupt and immoral for-profit
employer connected health insurance
system imagine that you are
self-employed and diagnosed with the
same thing that Senator John McCain has
been diagnosed with a brain cancer a
form of brain
answer called glioblastoma but you live
in rural Tennessee and your governor
working with Washington DC is cutting
Obamacare subsidies and there might not
be a single insurer offering a non group
plan where you live and treatment could
be a hundred thousand dollars what do
you do you don't have obama tweeting his
support to you you don't have every
media outlet talking about your
diagnosis and prognosis and and about
what's going on you have nothing and my
thoughts are with John McCain and his
family but also all the families that
are going through this exact same
diagnosis outside of the media spotlight
maybe without the resources that John
McCain has maybe without access to care
that John McCain has and some of them
precariously at risk of losing the
resources they do have as a result of
what our elected officials are thinking
about doing